Denis had had this notion of what he
called the good [ __ ] this developed in
the days after the ideas hypercar
Malaysian and he claimed he was like a
fam seems like a joke it wasn't clear
exactly what it was but it was this idea
that there was this hatch somewhere that
had been rolled into cow dung and cut
with cow dung and then infected with
psilocybin mycelium so that the mycelium
had completely replaced the cow [ __ ] in
this ball of hash of this hypothesized
kilos of hash somewhere in the world and
and so there was this and a cybernated
the good [ __ ] and at one point he at one
point he envisioned us actually forming
a rock-and-roll band which would play
instruments
would condense this stuff out of the air
over large audiences and you know we
would go on to her and at the end of the
tour history would be the whole thing
would be in a shambles because the Uncle
John's band really did come out of the
woodland that is said at one point he
predicted one night after he had been
moved to the river and was sort of in
semi incarceration
and so I left with my girlfriend of the
time and it may have even been the same
because the silver key
Oh an imploring rate and we may not lame
like a quarter-mile half a mile back
into the junk into this other place
where we were staying where the original
experiment had been done and so then we
get to the hut and it's pouring rain and
I had scored this kilo of Santa Marta
gold for the expedition and we have
loved nothing like this for Columbia
relatively rag weed for weeks
so my god and out to roll the nameless
joint and and I was fumbling with it and
I got this thing lit and this little
this little crumb was little burning
they fell on the floor and I lifted it
up and smelled it
the transubstantiation had occurred it
was you know like mazar-e-sharif
triple a Red Lion Ashish of some sort
and I know Ashish I and here we were in
the center of the Amazon in this Hut in
this pouring rain and I could tell that
it was the good it was the good [ __ ] he
didn't actually man yes and I showed the
woman who was with me and was easily led
one way or another but anyway she didn't
say it wasn't and I can I stayed up late
that night smoking this incredible hash
and waiting for the rain to stop so that
a first Frey light of dawn I could go
down to the river and confound my
critics with you know the stones and the
alchemical quintessence but King Chris
since the excreta Volta the good [ __ ]
here it was and soul as dawn broke and
the fog lifted I made my way
and sat down by the hammock cook was
sleeping forum a lie most for super is
pretty and certain elbowed her awake and
you know there were other instances
where this was the principle of work it
what it didn't work
everything has returned
like it was the Cinderella screw-up you
know it was just that I was a char girl
who washed rocks and there was no prints
and there was no coach and there was no
and and plus I was once again humiliated
in the presence of my critics who had
further reason to think that they would
check into the local mental health care
delivery system
these things happen
[Applause]